You just learned a lot of new things
about Bootstrap in order to complete
this project.
But how would somebody who already knows
Bootstrap approach our same problem?
Let's ask Jacques and find out.
To continue our series
of throwing random
things at him to get his attention,
let throw this ginormous penguin.
So we're going to actually take
this design and go through
it with Bootstrap, and turn it into at
least a first pass with HTML and CSS.
Okay, so here's an image that
we've been given by a designer.
And I'm just going to go through the
process that I go through when I take
something like this and
turn it into a web page.
I'm going to be using Bootstrap.
And I have a lot of working knowledge
of Bootstrap so when I use classes from
Bootstrap, don't worry if you don't
know them off the top of your head.
I use them almost everyday, so
they are right there for me.
But you can go look at
the documentation for Bootstrap.
It is very complete and
they have all kinds of demos and
things like that you
can really dive into.
So if there's something
you want to do and
you want to see if Bootstrap does it,
go check out those documents.
All right, so basically everything on
the web is in boxes at the moment.
So we start with the biggest box,
that's our browser.
The whole page here and
we'll work down from there.
If I'm looking at a design like this,
I'm going to start picking
out those boxes and so
the first one would be this top
area here with the logo and the name.
There's an HR, a horizontal rule,
that cuts through everything here.
We have this center area
with the main image.
And then we've got a box down
here that has the featured work.
And then sort of, the contents of that.
And so that'll be my first cut.
And when I'm looking at that,
I'm also seeing for instance
in this featured work area, there
are three boxes, three sets of content.
They're all identical and
I'll probably just be splitting that
whole row up into these three columns.
Same with the top here where we
a box that the logo's in and
a box that the name is in.
So I go through it and I look at it first.
It's really helpful to work through
the image in your head first and
sort of understand where your boxes are.
It'll make coding it up a lot easier.
Okay.
So jumping into the code here.
This is sort of just
my jumping off point.
This is mostly just boiler plate.
I'll walk through it
really quickly here.
We're basically just telling
the browser that yes we're HTML.
We're setting our doc type.
We're saying the language
in this case is English.
We're setting our character set here.
That basically just makes sure that the
browser is displaying the characters in
the way that I intend it to.
The next meta tag down here is
just telling Internet Explorer
use the best engine you've got, give
the user the most up to date experience.
The meta tag here is for mobile and
what we're saying is just sort of,
how to display the page
initially when it loads.
There's a title tag,
you should always name your pages and
we'll call this the Puppy Portfolio.
The thing below that is actually us
bringing Bootstrap into this page and
that's pretty much it for
the head of our document,
the body is where we're going to
start putting in the page itself.
So when we start up with Bootstrap,
we're going to put everything
inside of Bootstrap's container.
And then going back to our mock here
we'll just start with this top section.
So I'm going to make a row with
a logo and the name in it.
Now, I'm going to just split
this right down the middle.
We might decide to do it a little
off-center or something like that but for
right now, I'm just going to
cut it down the middle.
Everything in Bootstrap
is done in 12 columns, so
the whole width is divided up
into 12 different columns.
We'll start out splitting
it in half, six for each.
We'll drop in our logo here.
In images it'll be logo.png.
Always make sure you set alt text.
Alt text allows people to see and
understand your website.
When maybe the image didn't load or
if they're visually impaired,
their screen reader will read the
contents of this instead of obviously
being able to display
that image to them.
All right, so
here we're going to put in the name.
This whole area over here.
This Jane Doette and her subtitle.
And I'm just going to put these
in heading tags right now.
The h1 in general is the most important
thing, the title, the largest piece,
the largest heading on the website and
then go down from there.
So now, if we go over to our page,
we actually have our logo and
we have our name.
But you'll notice that the name doesn't,
we're not really looking a whole
lot like our mock at the moment.
The mock is right aligned and
capitalized and
here we are left aligned and
normally capitalized.
And so if we apply a style to this md-6
div here, the container of the name and
the subtitle, we're actually going to
apply those styles across everything.
Now, Bootstrap has some
nice built-in methods,
text-right and text-uppercase.
And those will pull all
the text to the right side, and
those will set the text
to all be uppercase and
again, don't expect to know all
of these going out the gate.
Bootstrap's documentation is
really good about this and if you
browsing through there you'll just pick
up things every time you look at it.
So now refreshing our page there we go
now, our text is on the right.
Everything's capitalized and
we'll move on from there.
So the next thing I'm looking at in
the mock is this horizontal rule and
we'll drop that in next.
All right, so you'll notice
that the horizontal rule for
Bootstrap is very thin,
we can come back and address that later.
Right now, we're just going to
go through with just the vanilla
capabilities of Bootstrap and
we'll worry about fine tuning and
doing all that kind of stuff later.
So going back to our mock the next
thing up is this big sort of central
image here.
That'll be taking up all 12 columns and
we'll drop that in.
So source of our images
will be in images.
So now, if we go to our page.
There's a puppy, one of the things
that you'll notice is that it's
actually coming off the edge
of the screen here.
It's actually overflowing
it's container.
So we can go and we can use Bootstrap
class responsive which will make
sure that, that image pulls itself in to
fit inside of its parent container so
that that the 12 columns,
this image now fits inside of it.
So there's our first puppy.
Now, the puppies
are starting to make sense.
Let's go back to our mock.
The next section we're going to work
on here is just this Featured Work.
So we'll consider Featured Work
to be its own 12 columns wide and
then we'll have each one of these sort
of featured work elements be their
own four columns wide each,
col 4 each and we'll just split it up.
And we're going to just work
through it top to bottom.
Featured Work is sort of the second
most important title on our page.
It's a section heading here,
so we're going to use an h2.
And you can flip back and forth in
between your browser and your coding
environment to make sure that sort
of just sanity check along the way.
Well when we have repeated
elements like this,
we can actually just code them up
once and copy and paste that it,
in this case a couple x more times, and
then update the elements within it.
It'll save us a little bit of typing and
a little bit of time.
All right, so there's our puppy.
There's our title.
So let's add again
that img-responsive and
we'll just make sure that puppy stays
inside of his little container.
So now, we've got one of them.
We can just copy paste over a few
more times and then modify those and
we should be coming up close
to what our mock looks like.
So let's go grab that text and
we'll just do some updates here.
Now, I'm copying and pasting to save
myself a little bit of time typing.
But make sure when you're copy paste
that you are actually updating
everything that you need to update.
It's very easy to introduce
errors when you're copying and
pasting because you might not see
one of the minor differences.
So maybe it's not changing this image
source or not changing the Alt text.
Just go through and
make sure that you're really
thorough when you copy paste.
It's a shortcut but make sure
you don't take it too casually.
All right.
So there are our featured work.